[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
Battle Network Legacy Collection
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
space-time distortions
there's the puking out dinosaurs all
over the planet
[Music]
for three years and ibius won't own up
the leviathan's malfunction
can you address the reports of EXO
fighter patrols on the island
reports of exercise patrols are simply
untrue
IBS is committing all possible resources
to the investigation
results locked sun setting temporal
instance
come on by drinks on me
there are hundreds of EXO Fighters
running around out there
everyone's armed and nobody knows
what'll happen next
one minute helping you the next minute
they're shooting you in the back
[Music]
you need to keep fighting so we can
figure out how to destroy the vine
it's trying to build stronger
excellencies so if you're pulling any
extra fire in your house back in time to
these bloody war games
like it or not the EXO suits keeping is
alive out there but the more we use it
the more it helps Leviathan
well that's not an option
[Music]
value team members prepare for
dimensional integration in 10 minutes
[Music]
[Music]
if you give an AI like Leviathan the
directive improve our exercise it has to
complete it doesn't matter whether that
takes a hundred tries million
all for the perfect City
more than that
at least give me the courtesy of looking
in the face whilst you do it
[Music]
okay Pinky four finger back to Middle
full wrist articulation
then we do it in reverse
begin
what the hell are you guys doing
it's a secret robot handshake
good morning Victoria
keep coming keep coming keep coming
[Music]
Safety First bud
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[ __ ] games
[Music]
[Music]
Shall We Begin
Showtime get into the rain don't expect
me to be a pushover
s
[Music]
one more song
perfect
[Music]
here comes a new Challenger
[Music]
tomorrow
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
Street Fighter six
scrap Heap ready start
you want to talk about it
[Music]
every night I have the same nightmare
that day that was hell
remember people screaming
what's going on
they get bitten then they turn
he wants it spread
spread
[Music]
it's terrifying
Leon
it's got to be another outbreak
I gotta go
don't do anything stupid
raccoon city was the beginning
can't let what happens
[Music]
if we went public with this
we could expose a conspiracy I can't get
anyone to go on record about outbreak
sorry I don't know what to tell you
[Applause]
we need to show the world that we are a
strong Nation capable of protecting the
interests of the Free World
we must be the source of Hope to those
who seek Freedom
we cannot allow anyone to interfere with
peace and prosperity
what are you here for that's classified
you know where the root of tariff comes
from
it starts with fear
[Music]
I will show you fear
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
go tell everyone
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
you will receive our most sacred body
it begins now
if I could just forget what happened
that night
pain
even for a second
this time
it can be different
it has to
I'm not sure if they are a hardcore
Resident Evil fans
or how many fans there are at Tango
but I spoke with some of my co-workers
who like Resident Evil
unlike all those years ago over the past
few years
people have started to recognize their
true re fans out there
[Music]
right we're really grateful for that the
one I've enjoyed the most recently
would have to be Resident Evil 7. that
was amazing wow thank you so much oh it
was insanely good ever since Resident
Evil 4 for me the best one has been
Resident Evil 7. seriously I played
Resident Evil 7 but I haven't tried out
Resident Evil Village
someone on my team has been playing re
for a long time also praised Resident
Evil 7 highly
they liked Resident Evil Village as well
so I asked them which they liked more
re7 or Ari Village and they said Ari
Village whoa I'm really happy to hear
that when I asked them why
they said that even though re7 was great
for the horror
Resident Evil has always really been
lacking when it comes to continuity with
previous games
foreign
that's why they as a fan of the whole
series
like Dari Village
which makes it feel like a true
continuation of the series a lot of fans
have probably been feeling that way
recently
probably in the past four or five years
I'd say thank you so much since Resident
Evil 7 focusing on horror was good
and when it came to directing as with
other titles each director did their
thing and they brought out something
great for each game by adding something
special for each of the titles
because they're supporting that has been
the case for all of the franchise titles
there are some players who became the
fans of the brand regardless of one
feature or another
but something that cannot be achieved if
the brand is still young like five to
ten years old
I was once more reminded of how big re
is as a brand
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
oh my company
how on Earth did you get in here oh
please don't fret I have no intention of
making a meal of you please call me the
Duke I'm but a humble Merchant for the
veil of goods to Lords and Ladies cross
fix
I do so strive to please my patrons I
hope we can become well acquainted but
of course it is not I who was on display
here but rather the Wares on offer for
you
I deal in all manner of Commerce but
today I trade in knowledge
this place is a veritable horde of
information
gathered from all throughout the Realms
of man
the more hard won the knowledge
higher the price
but you look like you're well aware of
the value of such
well since we're here I've got a few
morsels I'd love to share with such a
connoisseur please take a gander
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
happy half birthday Rose
I just want to find my daughter
I'll always be there for you no matter
what
[Music]
You Are My Precious Rose
and I didn't care
so long as we were together
I love you
dad
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
no matter
you're imminent demise
[Music]
anything happen to Rose
[Music]
I've got this
[Music]
I'm Kento kinoshita the director of the
Winter's expansion
gave his life to protect Rose
and in the end you see how she's grown
what kind of person is 16 year old Rose
that's what we wanted to explore so we
decided to have her at that age in this
expansion
said you had something important to tell
me
[Music]
she's trying to get rid of her unwanted
Powers but to do that she is forced to
return to the origin of her Misfortune
we thought that concept had a lot of
potential for an interesting story so
the setting this time is the realm of
Consciousness going back one more time
to that Village
the word nightmare is synonymous with
fear for instance if you've ever had a
childhood fever that caused a nightmare
even if they only last for an instant
like the feeling of being attacked by a
giant doll or something else similarly
so completely unrealistic can remain as
a fragment of a memory for the rest of
your life I wanted the core of the
feeling of fear to come from the kind of
memories and Nightmares that still haunt
people to this day
we wanted to choose characters that
would interest people who didn't play
The Mercenaries mode but would be
interested in playing a different type
of character
there are characters called Lords and
plain is them allows you to perform
amazing skills and attacks that a
regular human could not being able to
play them was more fun so that's why we
chose those characters
we balance things to ensure that as
little time as possible is spent waiting
for enemies to appear for instance if a
player doesn't finish off an enemy it
will chase after the player we made
adjustments like this to raise the tempo
and increase the fun of defeating enemy
after enemy
in an FPS you experience the game world
as if it's through your own eyes
so it can be incredibly scary to play a
horror game from that perspective
there are some players out there who
might find it too scary or experience
motion sickness in the first person
perspective they might not enjoy the FPS
genre
so we wanted to make a third person mode
for those players to enjoy the game to
its fullest
while there's still a sense of immersion
and fear with a third-person perspective
when the player character dies it
doesn't feel as much like you yourself
or die and you can enjoy playing it as a
game to confront the fear that it
creates which is a very different
experience I think third person mode is
a perfect way for people to return to
Resident Evil Villages as both a game
and an experience wouldn't it be okay to
show Ethan's face he gave that question
some thought so even in third person
mode if you try to turn the camera to
see his face Ethan will look away and
you're not quite able to get a good look
each of the three editions are
interesting in their own way and we hope
you really enjoy the expansion please
look forward to it thank you
foreign
for you
starting today a demo for the third
person mode will be available
here is the release date and platforms
for the demo
this demo can be played for a total of
60 minutes in third person mode or the
previously existing first person mode
[Music]
Mission adjustment
no doesn't change anything
in a while since we fought together
Captain doing nothing but recon's gotten
me out of shape
let's have some fun people
move out
yes okay
[Music]
[Music]
all right foreign
[Music]
[Music]
verse is free content for those who own
Resident Evil Village or Resident Evil
Village Gold Edition
this game has cross play and you can
fight players across all platforms
those who already own Resident Evil
Village will be able to participate in
the Early Access period starting October
24th additionally updates are planned
for Resident Evil are reversed after it
has been officially released here are
some details for the Early Access and
updates
foreign
[Music]
will be playable on even more platforms
hello everyone my name is Jeremy sandmel
and I'm part of the GPU software team at
Apple during the keynote at our
worldwide developers conference Capcom
announced Resident Evil Village will be
coming to the Mac later this year and
will take full advantage of the power
and performance of Apple silicon we
couldn't be more excited that the game
will be available to Mac users around
the world beginning Friday October 28th
Resident Evil Village is the first
Project based on capcom's re engine to
support the mac and runs natively on
Apple silicon and since the game is
optimized to take advantage of metal 3
features like metal effects upscaling
gameplay is incredibly responsive with
high frame rates and beautiful visuals
this means that every Mac from MacBook
Air to Mac Studio will be able to play
Resident Evil village with ease stay
tuned for more information soon
[Music]
thank you
hello everyone I am midoro from ubitus
and I am yonatani from ubitus it is a
great honor to be taking part in This
Global project of the Resident Evil
franchise on cloud with Capcom with the
launch of the cloud version not only
fans from Japan but from all over the
world can play the game on Nintendo's
switch without thinking about the
download time
the application size is small but the
users can experience smooth gameplay of
up to 60 FPS while playing it in
multiple modes that Nintendo switch
offers such as TV mode tabletop mode and
handheld mode it is great to be able to
focus on the gameplay without thinking
about storage space or the download time
you can also check your network
environment by playing the demo before
you pre-order or purchase the game
the game can be pre-ordered or purchased
after you play the demo this is to make
sure that those who are playing a cloud
game for the first time or may have
concerns can test it and enjoy the game
with 5G mobile network technology being
so wide widespread recently barrier
between
playing it on cloud is getting smaller
and smaller we hope you will enjoy it
and Marvel at the technology of cloud
gaming as well as its future through the
release of Resident Evil Village cloud
Resident Evil Village Cloud will be
available on October 28th in the
Winter's expansion DLC will follow on
December 2nd
furthermore re2 Cloud will launch on
November 11th followed by the re3 cloud
on November 18th and re-7 Cloud will be
available on December 16th
how delightful
such delectable information
ought to be safe
oh what's that you want more
what a greedy thing you are no it's
quite all right I love to see a healthy
appetite I'll do my best to Sage your
hunger come have a look at this
[Music]
hello everyone
I'm the producer of Resident Evil 4.
yoshiaki hirabayashi I'm here today to
deliver the newest information about the
title
first please enjoy this new gameplay
footage
foreign
home
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
situation
the hell is going on
no [ __ ] way
foreign
Bruce
this is Gondor one hunnigan here what's
your sit rep president's daughter baby
eagle
so likely she's in this Village
our Intel is correct then well done
Something's Happened to people here
my escorts are
gotta go talk later
thank you
kill me for the repairs later
foreign
[Music]
let's go
[Music]
what did you think
as you just saw
we are paying respect to the original
game's World while implementing new
ideas and state-of-the-art Graphics to
strengthen the Core Concepts of the
title
you think this game will provide a fresh
experience with a sense of familiarity
if you played the original that both
newcomers and Veterans to Resident Evil
4 will enjoy
the gennados will have all new ways to
attack they are closing in on Leon
during his mission and will attack with
an even greater variety of methods than
in the original release Leon fights back
with Firearms close combat Maneuvers a
newly added Perry using his ninth and
more
thank you
resource management and upgrade elements
are critical for survival
just as in the original using the
attache case effectively will be key in
addition to managing the weapons and
items you carry and synthesizing herbs
this also allows you to craft ammunition
and other items
stranger of course we can't forget the
merchant
you can purchase weapons and items and
customize them to suit your playstyle
we're starting we've also added a trade
mechanic where rare gems you've
collected can be exchanged for special
items
we are rebuilding the original game
while respecting its core experience
adding new ideas and modernizing the
play field
now I'd like to share some new
information regarding this product's
release
we announced that Resident Evil 4 will
also be available on Playstation 4. in
addition to PlayStation 5 Xbox series X
and Xbox series s and PC
the PlayStation 4 version can be
upgraded to the PlayStation 5 digital
version at no additional cost
I'd like to introduce two other
additions we are preparing for players
looking for more than the standard
edition
the first is the deluxe edition which
will be available for all platforms
this includes additional content such as
costumes special weapons a treasure map
and more
next is the physical only collector's
edition
this Edition includes the contents of
the deluxe edition as well as a leon
figure a special map art book soundtrack
and more
also pre-orders start today
if you pre-order the standard edition
you'll receive the attache case gold and
special charm handgun ammo
foreign
if you pre-order the deluxe edition or
collector's edition you'll receive the
standard edition pre-order bonuses as
well as attache case classic and special
charm green herb
now if you pre-order the digital version
on the PlayStation Store you'll receive
a mini soundtrack
you can secure these bonuses by
pre-ordering Resident Evil 4.
thank you for watching so far we are
working hard to create a game that
everyone will enjoy
so please look forward to it before I go
we have one more update for you let's
take a look
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
where are you
[Music]
your soul
requires cleansing
foreign
are you in here
just let me go listen
here in the president's orders
what is that
what can we do a lot of Slams are
escaping we need to go
you can stop right there
beta
who are you what are you doing here
my faithfulness
Ashley run
portion of her flow with his crates
what's happening to me now
abandon your body leave the girl she's
lost no matter what
now that he has chosened death
oh you gotta be kidding me
thank you
foreign
did you enjoy the Resident Evil showcase
let's recap
first Resident Evil Village Gold Edition
Launches on Friday October 28th if you
already own Resident Evil Village you
could purchase the Winter's expansion
DLC separately the Winter's expansion
includes three additional modes
the third person mode so you can enjoy
the main game in A New Perspective the
powered up the mercenaries additional
orders and the new story campaign
Shadows of rose
oh yes a demo for the third person mode
will be available today
don't forget
The Early Access period for Resident
Evil are in verse begins October 24th
for all owners of Village Resident Evil
Village Cloud playable on Nintendo
switch via a cloud service will be
available starting October 28th Resident
Evil 2 Resident Evil 3 and Resident Evil
7 are also coming to Nintendo switch via
Cloud at a later date
also the Mac version of Resident Evil
Village will be released on October 28th
the newest entry in the series Resident
Evil 4 will release on Friday March 24th
2023 and you can pre-order it today
we hope you look forward to it
thank you very much for watching
well well looks like you've had your
filled with such a grand display I
should hope so oh I'm afraid I have an
appointment I must attend to just a bit
of bartering with another merchants
an odd chap but his information is good
and I shouldn't say anymore anyway I do
hope I'll see you again I'll strive to
prepare a suitably satisfying stock of
goods